pas
[Musique]
le conseil départemental à célébrer
l'aïd ce dimanche 30 juin dans le jardin
de la villa du département
après la lecture du coran marilyn
soubadou vice président de la
collectivité a souhaité la bienvenue à
l'ensemble de la communauté musulmane de
l'île
il a été un moment fort comme j'existe
tout à leur discours c'est un moment
il manque de la réunion se retrouvent
pour le partage pour un bon vivre
ensemble et comme le fait si bien le
président du conseil départemental série
de michael c'est de fêter en tous les
cas d'apporter de laisser la place à
toutes les les
les les origines à toutes les religions
de pouvoir fêter leurs temps forts ici
au département je crois que gak cette
équité lac est important que tout le
monde s'y retrouve sur un lieu où le
département de partage entre l'état ce
bon vivre ensemble à rennes
le public a pu profiter de divers
ateliers mettant en avant les traditions
de l'islam est né
c'est un moyen d'embellir le corps de
façon naturelle et temporaires c'est une
plante à base d'un homme qui s'appelle
la sonia on fabrique la pâte avec les
feuilles et de l'eau ensuite on peut
aussi bien faire sur la peau pense qu'on
peut aussi utiliser dans les cheveux
faire la coloration on met le henné lors
des grandes occasions comme des
fiançailles un mariage une naissance
mais aussi lors de l'aïd comme
aujourd'hui par exemple une journée qui
valorise un islam riche un islam ouvert
sur le monde qui contribue au
renforcement jack un vivre ensemble remy
et je suis toujours
la présent avec coupes de bois
et je rencontre aussi
les amis de l'état du fait religieux
c'est vraiment un moment de
rassemblement qui met en évidence notre
vivre ensemble réunionnais ce qui
réussit c'est l' équilibre c'est
l'harmonie c'est pour ça que nous sommes
heureux de vivre à la réunion parce
qu'ici se réunit toutes les cultures
tous les continents c'est le frottement
de toutes ces cultures réunis qui nous
font vivre la reine tels que dilemme
line d'une fête de partage qui reflète
parfaitement le mois sacré de ramadan
[Musique]